à
eh ben
c'est tout
commencent à arriver
je pense que pour une tournée au début
de cet équipement j'ai l'impression et
il a pu me relâcher coppola filmé pour
la 4e fois là bas tu reviens avec amiens
où les camions bordeaux c'est
invraisemblable où j'ai l'impression
qu'on va descendre un peu trop de quoi
tu vas voir tu vas voir
gauche cécile brossard voilà cette année
mais tous les espoirs des points d'eau
questionné par effacement des vieux des
bouts de bébé et deux enfants se vend
ces bons ne faut pas s'ils retournent
identique en après terme avec le vent on
va se taper un petit coup de vent on en
avait
je suis toujours en garde à vue et on
attend car je reviens à y aura bien un
tour doucement de ses photos en gros ça
voilà deux soirs dès ce mardi
oh
sauf la vache dans l'audit en seconde
je veux monter je vais m'en fais pas je
vois comment fait on